yahoo pulls out of china citing
challenging environment pretty
interesting for yahoo to make a story
out of this by the way this is an ap
news story the withdrawal was largely
symbolic as many of the company services
were already blocked by the china
china's digital censorship but recent
government moves to expand its control
over tech companies generally including
is domestic giants may have tipped the
scales for yahoo yahoo's the latest
foreign company to exit china google
gave up several years ago microsoft's
professional networking platform
linkedin said last month it would
shutter its chinese side replacing it
with a job board instead the departures
illustrate the choices internet
companies face in a huge potential
market but one where the government
requires them to censor content and
keywords deemed politically sensitive or
inappropriate chinese laws stipulate
that companies operating in the country
must hand over data if requested by
authorities making it difficult for
western firms to operate in china as
they may also face pressure back home
over giving in to china's demands okay
so uh zenner i'm going to you first and
i'm going to ricky okay
oh start talking now
i know i would talk
i was in the metabolism my bad
let me exit real quickly and deal with
humans third dimension um
clearly it's becoming very difficult for
tech companies to uh interact with the
chinese government and
take away the population 1.3 billion the
biggest market in the world for them to
be bailing this quickly uh speaks
volumes you know so i'll let you guys
talk more about it i'm waiting for the
chinese taiwan porn
math teacher and then i can really give
you some yeah
if you if you
if you um
really compare what's going on in china
and what's going on here tom would it's
not it's it's really
no different because what america is
using is just pressure what the
uh
as far as what you can say what you
can't say the chinese government is just
simply telling you you're not gonna do
it
american government is not doing that
but what they're doing is they're
grabbing the media and telling you you
can't do that i don't know i don't know
if i'm making sense yes yes
america is doing the same thing
it's yes so it's like chinese government
are just like straight up don't care
and with us
we're experiencing the same thing as
china except that we're using
uh the social um
justice warriors to do it i think that
to me that's i think you make a really
good they're almost like
he makes a great point it's the same
thing it's like it's like there's two
cars are speeding one china one in
america right in america
the guys in the cars next to you start
yelling at you and are pointing at you
in china they hit the remote control
button and your car stops that's it so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye
[Music]